[Music]
what are you excited for today you know
what I'm actually hosting the Loreal
stage and it's just so inspiring to be
around so many you know men and women
that are here for one reason and that's
because they have a passion for the
beauty industry I watch her and your
cousin it's my cousin yeah your cousin
Nadia you're hilarious on Instagram and
I thought she's she's also your makeup
artist
she's my makeup artist she's my best
friend my cousin we actually have a show
coming out it's called the platinum
night life we air in October so you can
see all the debauchery and shenanigans
starting October good to know good to
know I saw you were you guys filmed your
bachelorette party yeah yeah it got
crazy but uncrazy you know girl girl fun
crazy so yeah does that mean there's a
wedding coming with Miguel soon I mean
there's definitely a wedding happening
of the planning there's a wedding
happening I love it I love it I got to
keep that secret but that ring though it
speaks volumes thank you so much
[Music]
you